The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR 1: So we want
to maximize time today,
both to make sure
that we're doing--
all of the presentations
get good feedback,
but also so you
have time afterwards
to make some changes.
So, if you haven't
signed in yet,
come on down sign
up while I talk.
Just get that out of
the way really quick.
Schedule for today is,
we're going to probably be
done with rehearsals by 2:30.
After 2:30 we are going to
have Luke from OpenCourseWare
interviewing teams and producers
from teams about the class.
So, we're thinking about
how many minutes per team?
LUKE: Not too long.
10 to 15, casual chat.
PROFESSOR 1: Yep,
casual chat is optional,
but I would appreciate
it if at least people
who did production and Scrum
Master roles would talk to him.
But it could be the entire
team talking with him,
and maybe one or two people
dominating the conversation.
That's OK.
The goal for this
is for people who
are looking at the
OpenCourseWare site,
particularly teachers
who might want
to use these materials
in their classes,
to find out from the student
perspective what students got
out of the class.
Because it's kind of
like student evaluations.
We're going to be out of the
room for that period of time.
So that means after 2:30
we're out of the room,
Luke's doing interviews,
and your teams
are doing whatever
teamwork you need
to do to get ready
for the demonstrations
and presentations on Wednesday.
PROFESSOR 2: Whatever
you say to the camera,
we will not even get
a chance to see it
before we give you grades.
So you can whale
on if you'd like.
PROFESSOR 1: Please do.
Or at least, please be
honest-- let's try for that.
I should also note,
student evaluations
are available online.
Please fill those out.
We're going to-- actually
it's a great period
of time from 3:00
to 4:00 in class
today to just open
up your browser
and fill out your
student evaluation,
right here and now so that
you get that out of the way.
And again, that feedback's going
to be really helpful for us.
It's going to
change how we teach
the course in the next year.
We change it every year based on
feedback we get from students.
So topics you thought you
wanted to hear more about,
topics you thought
we covered too much,
whatever feedback you have
for us, do let us know.
Last announcement we have
a guest here, [? Leigh, ?]
from Odyssey magazine.
GUEST SPEAKER: It's a
kid's science magazine
for kids aged 9 to 14.
And we're doing an
issue devoted to gaming.
And [INAUDIBLE]
graciously allowed me
to come and observe
you guys as you
rehearse your presentations.
And I'm going to be
taking some pictures,
and I may ask some questions.
I have some photo releases
I'm going to need you
to sign if I use your photos.
So I'll pass those around.
The good news is, if you don't
want me to use a photo of you,
don't sign it.
Because I can't use
your picture without it.
So that's just an easy
way to handle that.
So, I'm just going to pass
a pile of these around.
And if you're willing to
let me use your photograph,
fill one out.
Thank you.
PROFESSOR 1: OK.
All right, so for our order of
presentations just for today,
not necessarily for
Wednesday-- we'll
figure out the actual order
by the end the class today.
We're going to start
with Heat Wave,
then Hello Waves, then SNAP!,
then saving Gora Gora, then
Cholera Control.
What we're asking
you to do is come up,
plug-in the computer
that's going
to be used to demonstrate
your game and make sure
your game works
on the projector.
The display resolution the
native display resolution
is 1280 by 1024.
If you're doing a 4 3, or
1280 by 768 if you're doing
widescreen.
It shouldn't make a huge
difference for your slides,
but it might be a
problem for your game.
So, make sure you're
coming up, doing
a quick two- or
three-minute check
to make sure the game works.
Afterwards, plug-in
your slide presentation,
and we'll just go step by step.
One thing I'd like to
know from each team
is how many speakers
do you think
you're going to have--
how many main speakers you
have in your presentations.
So, starting with Heat Wave,
how many speakers do you have?
One.
Hello Waves?
Two.
SNAP!?
AUDIENCE: Two.
PROFESSOR 1: Saving Gora Gora?
AUDIENCE: Five.
PROFESSOR 1: Five.
And Cholera Control?
AUDIENCE: One for
now, maybe two.
Not sure.
PROFESSOR 1: So, for Heat
Waves, Hello Waves, SNAP!
And Cholera Control--
actually for all of you,
whoever is doing
the most speaking,
strap this little thing on.
For everybody else,
when you speak,
make sure you are standing
on the normal spot in front
of this, so that the
microphone can capture you.
If you have-- for volume
control, it is over here.
Hopefully you've
used this before.
It's set at about midway.
Take a note of all
the different settings
you are using when you're
plugging in your stuff
to the projector, so we can make
things go fast on Wednesday.
Any questions?
All right take four more
minutes in your teams
to get yourself
ready, and Heat Wave,
please come up at 1:15
to plug-in your game.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: No, so time
yourself with the clock.
Take a note of your own time.
We're not enforcing
time limit right now.
We're concentrating on content.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Well, hello, my name
is Mary [? from Providence ?]
and today I'm
representing team Heat Wave.
We made a game about heat
waves, not surprisingly.
And these are the
people on our team.
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a minute.
So, first of all, our
game was about heat waves,
and the main goal our game was
to educate Red Cross workers
about what to do when a heat
wave was upcoming or was
currently in progress.
How do you prepare
for it, and also what
do you do to deal with it.
And while we focused
on these goals,
our design goals were more
specifically usability, play--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
How did I get that
far without someone
pointing that out to me?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GUEST SPEAKER: OK, we're going
to start over if that's OK.
Do you mind?
I really didn't get that
far in, so that's OK.
Heat waves-- oh, but now
I can't see the slides.
OK.
Heat Waves, this is our team.
Heat Waves is a game to talk
and explain to Red Cross workers
what to do in order to both
prepare for heat waves,
and also what to do once
you're in a heat wave.
And that was the
purpose of our game.
And while we had those goals
for our game educationally,
our goals overall for
the design process
were playability,
usability, and education.
Usability was first, because
if the game isn't usable,
no one's going to use it.
Same with playability, if you
can't play through the game,
then it's kind of useless.
And finally, our main
goal was education,
because we really
wanted this game
to serve a purpose, which
was to educate people.
For our design process,
we did the same process
that most of the people
in this class did.
We started off
with brainstorming.
Then we went into team
formation, responsibilities
breakdown, and then
just constantly
updating, using Trello and
different Scrum features.
I'm going to talk
about all of these
in a little bit more depth.
So first of all,
brainstorming, we
started off right on the
get-go, drawing on the board.
What do we want this
game to look like?
What are going to be
the main parts of it?
And we actually settled on a
somewhat complicated design,
with the main screen
a dialogue system,
and then kind of
an options menu.
And once we had this, we
actually formed our team.
This is our team minus-- I don't
think Joe's in this picture
because he was sick that day.
And one thing you notice is
we had a team of nine people.
So it was a lot of people
doing a lot of stuff.
So we had to really
deal with that.
And one way we dealt with
that was using Scrum.
We had a lot of emails.
But the way we managed that is,
we learned from previous times
that if you have one giant email
thread it gets overwhelming,
you don't see everything.
So we separated it, had a
couple different email threads
based on different
topics and subgroups.
And then also we
updated our Trello.
One thing we realized
really quickly
is that Trello is not so good
for listing every single Scrum.
So you kind of have to
have a to-do, a done,
and a working on right now,
just for future reference.
And that's kind of how we
organized ourselves later on.
And then just
because it's Scrum,
it's an iterative process,
which is the picture.
Next, we had a lot
of group meetings.
And something we spent
not as much time in class
because we spent a lot
of time outside of class.
We had a bunch of meetings
where we had snacks,
and we would all just sit around
for like three, four hours,
and work.
And those were really
productive times for us,
because it was a time where
everyone who was there
was really dedicated
to fixing bug
after bug, issue after
issue, getting things done.
And they were really what
made our game come together
as much as it did.
So, focus test, we
ran four focus tests.
And each of our focus tests
had a different theme.
So once we had our team together
and we were building the game,
there were different things
working at different times.
So for the first focus test,
we had a low-fidelity prototype
that with digital, and
it was a Python game.
And we've tested concept--
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in a second.
The second one we tested
our initial unity game,
and we looked for
over-arching issues.
The third test, we worked
on visuals, just how can
we emotionally resonate
with our audience.
And the fourth test
was game balancing,
because at the end of the
day, once you have everything
together, it's really easy to
ignore if the game is balanced
or not.
So the first test we ran was a
concept of general mechanics.
So as I said earlier, our
general focus was education.
It was our big
goal, and we wanted
to make sure the type
of game we were building
could really convey
information and teach
the audience about something.
So if any of you played
our Python test game,
you would remember
that you basically
had a bunch of people you
could choose to talk to.
And if you talked to them, you
could offer them water, tell
them to go inside.
And they'd either listen
to you or ignore you.
And you just went
that way in loops
until either everyone fainted
or everyone went inside.
And what we learned from that
was, first of all, it worked.
People were noticing,
OK, I'm going
to focus on the
drunk guy, I'm going
to focus on the older person,
try to get them water first.
Because they faint more quickly.
And the other thing
we noticed right away
is something we did try to try
to make this game more lively,
is we had fun dialogue.
So for example, the
first quote up there
was like a more
factual, drinking water
even when you're
not too thirsty is
important in this type of heat.
That's a very true
fact about heat waves.
You're just supposed to drink
more water than you need to.
And then the second
one is just more fun
trying to make it more
lively, hide your wife,
hide your [? kill, ?]
it's heat wave.
So that's something we
experimented with early-on,
having fun or dialogue
to kind of increase
the excitingness of the game.
So, the second
focus task we really
were looking for
overarching issues,
and it was our first
unity-based game,
so we are working with issues
with our dialogue system,
issues with how is
the playability.
Does this concept of interacting
and thinking about education
still work in this
unity-based game, where it's
less of like a, oh, there's
just these old person
or young person,
which one do I choose?
Instead now you
have these figures.
And we tested this
out a little bit.
We found the educational aspect
was still coming through,
but we had a lot of playability
and usability issues.
So, we needed to
majorly revamp that.
So then we got our
focus test three,
where we focused on the visuals.
So once we went
through play test two,
we realized, OK, we can fix a
lot of this usability stuff.
And now we want to see, can
we make this game emotionally
resonate with the players.
And make it feel like
less of just kind of like,
I'm sitting there looking at
this red screen and it's like,
argh.
So we had this, and
what we were looking
to talk to people about was
the different characters,
were they still
prioritizing in this scene.
And it turns out they weren't,
because those labels didn't
move with the people.
And even if the
labels had moved,
people said the labels
were too small to read,
they were confusing-- really
should just get rid of them,
and instead either add
little icons or caricatures
of different types of people
in order to choose who to help.
So those were the kinds
of questions we asked.
And we actually showed
them a sample artwork
of a redone homeless
person drawing.
And people said that, that
was a lot more informative
and that way we didn't have
to have like little text
that no one could read.
So focus test 3 was
really about the visuals,
and we really re-did a lot
of our visuals based on that.
Sorry, this mouse is a
little non-responsive.
Finally, focus
test four-- I think
you all probably
had one of these--
was just game balancing.
The end condition of
our game is basically
when people faint, how
many people have fainted.
And if a certain number
of people have fainted,
then we stop the game.
And the problems with that was
that it was, at first, there
was too many people, and
everybody was dying right away.
And then we instead of ramped
up the number of people,
and then there was an
issue where, you were fine,
you were fine, you
were fine, and then
suddenly everyone died
on the fourth day.
Because there were suddenly
100 people, and you
could not help them all.
So focus test four
really focused on that,
and trying to
balance the game out.
Along the way, we
made some bad choices.
Every team does.
And the main ones we
made was, we decided
to depend on external code.
And while we thought
it would allow
us to make a more
complicated game,
we didn't really
foresee how much
we would have to
adjust ourselves
around the external code.
It's a two-way street.
And so it kind of impeded
our progress sometimes.
It added a lot more
complexity, things
that we weren't expecting.
And then the other thing
we made a mistake on,
which I'd like to
emphasize, is we
focused on education, which
was a great thing to do,
but we forgot to focus on fun.
And one thing we did
to compensate for it,
as I mentioned, is add
that dialogue, that banter,
that makes something
that's kind of dull
a little more interesting.
But even so, I think one
thing that if we went back
and we did things
differently, we'd
focus on fun as a
number-one priority,
along with playability,
usability, and education.
So ours became a pretty
standard learning game,
as we talked about them.
Good choices, we had a
lot of group meetings
with snacks, great idea.
Turns out people come
if you have snacks.
Just if you were wondering.
And then we prioritize.
So everybody prioritized.
But one thing we had to
deal with, because we
had such a large
team, was not everyone
was available at the same time.
So it was really
prioritizing not only
based on what needed
to be done but even
if something kind of had already
been assigned who can actually
work on this right now and
get it done, and like when
are they going to get it done.
So we really worked
with that and kept
iterating and
figuring out, based
on what needed to get done right
now, who was going to do it.
So the game itself is composed
of really three screens
but a couple of them
have sub-components.
So, the Start screen with
an instruction screen;
the main game, which has the
daytime screen and a newspaper
scene in it, which is like the
end of each day you see that;
and then the end
screen, just you
can take a look at all of these.
So originally, this
was our start screen.
Main feedback with that
was, it was not pretty,
and it was not informative.
So when we redid it, we
added an instruction screen,
which is actually still
having a little bit of bugs
with the readability.
But what we did
was we added a way
for players who didn't play the
game before to find out what
they actually needed to do.
And then the actual game, the
original, we had-- I showed you
on our focus test two
and then our focus
test three with the people
moving, but the labels not
moving.
We really iterated
the main game to make
that as usable as possible.
And our final result-- well
this is actually in progress.
So one thing we updated
in progress that I almost
forgot to mention, was that
we saw in focus test two
and focus test three that
visuals really important.
And one thing we
weren't displaying
at all that was
very educationally
important, that Pablo
actually mentioned,
was that as people are about to
faint, they usually get sick.
If you see somebody
who's about to faint,
they'll like start sweating, and
turn red, and all this stuff.
And in our game, they just
kind of keeled over and died.
So, we needed a way
to implement that.
But we couldn't necessarily
like draw a million different
character art.
So, we decided on
the simple solution
was just to add a little-- that
little circle, like the thing
above their heads, you can all
see it with the exclamation
point.
And that was something
we did in progress.
And finally we integrated that
with the new character art,
and this is the
final game-- I don't
know what those squares are,
they're not in our game.
But you can see the people
are a lot more descriptive.
I think that's pretty
obviously that's an old person,
they have a walker.
And we had to rely on these
caricatures of people, which
really worked out in terms of
like getting visual feedback
when we talked to people.
They were much more responsive
to this than like labels
or even like little symbols.
They really liked the art.
And finally-- not finally,
but the other part of our main
game was the newspaper scene.
And initially we just had a
lot of information displayed,
and no one actually read it,
because they didn't think they
could do anything about it.
And they also just didn't
like looking at it.
It was confusing.
So we re-did that, and so
made it a little more visually
appealing.
And something we did
that I didn't mention
on the previous side
about the main scene,
is that we actually added
more longer-term options.
So this was more relevant
as you were playing.
Because if it was
cooler on a day,
you could start
installing umbrellas.
And then you would
actually be like, OK, well,
it's actually 115
today, so I'm not
going to install
any umbrellas, I'm
just going to try to
give people water.
And then finally-- so
originally at the end
of our game, as you can
see, there was no end scene.
And that's kind of important.
So, people really
wanted feedback
as to-- they didn't just
want the game to restart,
they wanted to
know how they did.
Even if it's educational,
part of that fun that
was something we
obviously didn't focus on,
was just knowing, oh, I
actually did pretty well.
This many people-- like
I lasted this many days,
or this many people like
went inside because of me.
And that's because we
weren't focusing on fun,
we didn't even think about the
importance of an end screen.
Right?
So, when we re-did it,
we added this end screen,
and it tells you how
long you survived.
So, two hours, five days, you
can get a sense of how long
can I keep it up and make sure
everybody was working out well.
So that's our whole game.
And looking back at this
whole process, something
we've discussed as a team
that we would do differently,
is passion.
So one thing about heat waves we
all thought initially, oh, it's
such cool topic, heat
waves, it gets hot.
And then we read about
it, and it was actually
a surprisingly
simple phenomenon.
It gets hot, people drink water,
go inside, and that's about it.
There's not really a lot
of complexity to the issue.
And so a lot of us lost
our passion very early on.
And I think if we were
going to do this again,
we'd somehow incorporate
something in addition
to the heat waves
that would make us
more passionate about the game.
The other thing we'd do
differently is accountability.
Just making sure that--
with such a large team
you have to really keep track
of everyone doing everything.
We really focused
on prioritizing
who was like actually
had time to give
and making sure they got tasked
on-- which worked out really
well.
But at the same time,
there were people
who sometimes were
kind of lost and didn't
know where the game was going.
Because we weren't
always on the same page
with such a large team,
nine people's a lot.
But it still worked
out really well.
And I'd say that
given everything, we
did pretty well with it.
And if we were going
to do more features,
something we talked about
was more long-term options,
people like those.
They made it more
fun, because you
had more of an
optimization problem
if you had more
long-term choices.
Those were kind of hard to
think of, because in heat waves
there aren't that many.
Like you can install an
AC unit, and then maybe
a water fountain.
But we were thinking maybe we
can make this a bigger scope
game, add multiple
environments so you
have more long-term options.
And really build up the
complexity over time,
so this game can be more
realistic of a community
as a whole instead of
a single environment.
And that's really
what we wanted to do.
Thank you so much.
Are there any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR 1: Oh, so
comments about presentation.
Anybody up there?
Yes, so can you load up your
game make sure your game works?
Can somebody come down here
from the team and do that?
And you can answer questions
while we-- so feedback from us
then about the presentation.
The main question
I had-- like you
covered a whole
bunch of stuff, which
is really good-- the
things we're asking for,
what went right,
what went wrong,
you did in a different
format, but you got to it,
and that was fine,
that was good.
The one thing I would have
loved more information on,
if you can fit it, is
the external code issue.
Specifically, what
was the external code,
why was it in there,
what did you think
it was going to help you with?
And then what did end up
like-- just a couple lines
of those details about
GUEST SPEAKER: More specific.
PROFESSOR 1: More specific.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yes,
definitely. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: And really
what is it giving you
that basic unity
wasn't giving you.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK,
absolutely. [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 2: Let's see,
I like the structure,
as [? Rick ?] said,
you got to everything.
But actually the way how
you structured it also
works really well
for all the points
that you intended to hit.
If we are following
this particular order
of presentation--
PROFESSOR 1: We're
not necessarily,
we're going to figure
out what the order is
after we do the all.
PROFESSOR 2: Whoever
goes first will probably
need to explain who
Pablo is to the audience.
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh, sorry--
PROFESSOR 2: No, no,
no, it's not something
that you would
necessarily have expected.
But whoever goes
first on Wednesday,
if you talk about
any of the clients,
you have to assume that
your audience doesn't
know who the clients are.
And different teams
had different clients
that they were talking to, too.
So do just explain [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 1: We'll introduce--
basically we're making games
about the topic, but
your specific topic--
GUEST SPEAKER: If I
have to mention Pablo,
I should say who it is, or I
shouldn't mention him directly.
PROFESSOR 1: Yes.
PROFESSOR 2: Yes, or just
give his name and who he is,
that will do wonders.
Something for anybody who's
using Google Presentations,
Google Slides or whatever
that thing is called,
I think the Ask button
brings up your notes.
So if you have notes-- I wasn't
sure if you were relying on--
GUEST SPEAKER: No, I just wanted
to be able to see the slides.
That's why [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR 2: You also get
a little preview slide.
So if you hit the Ask
button, you bring that up.
Also it automatically
brings up the,
"Google Drive is
using full screen,
click this to make
it disappear."
And that's really distracting.
So whoever is using Google
drives, make sure you do that.
And you may want to
use the keyboard,
because the mouse was not--
GUEST SPEAKER: It
was flipping out.
PROFESSOR 2: Yes, it was
there was not cooperating.
GUEST SPEAKER: I brought it
for the actual game play,
but we're not playing
the game today.
PROFESSOR 2: OK, so
recharge, and if it
starts to give you that
same problem, for the slides
at least, you may want to
just avoid using the mouse.
PROFESSOR 1: Actually,
putting it in mirror mode,
too, instead of two
screens, would at least
give you a full-screen
version of the slides.
The speaker notes give
you a very tiny version
of the slides.
PROFESSOR 2: Yes, it was
very hard to see, actually.
So mirroring your
screen back and forth
will also make it so that you
don't every have to do that.
GUEST SPEAKER: Can
you write that down?
PROFESSOR 2: I can email this
actually, at least these notes.
At the beginning of
your presentation.
If you can just--
when you introduce
that your game's
about heat waves,
before you go into
the things that you
did, if you can just
very briefly talk
about what Red Cross workers
have to do in heat waves.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK, yeah.
PROFESSOR 2: Yeah,
of course, if that's
after you demonstrate
your game, then
that may not be so necessary.
But just to give
people an-- just
to make sure that before
you start talking about this
is what your team did, just
give people an idea of this
is what you're going
to do in the game.
PROFESSOR 1: And you
all have a choice
of demoing the game before
the presentation or after.
It's whatever works best
for your presentation.
PROFESSOR 2: So if you're
showing the game first
you may not need
to describe this,
but it if you're showing the
game after your talk then
you definitely need
to explain that.
When you say, "over-arching
issues," as a bullet point,
that tells me nothing.
It's like, you had a big issue.
But then later on of
course you went into detail
and talked-- oh, it
was about dialogue,
it was about learning,
and stuff like that.
I think the first time you
introduce a bullet point,
say over-arching
issues, and you say,
such as, the dialogue, bugs,
and the learning, very quickly,
just so that bullet
point means something.
[? Rick ?] had already mentioned
the thing about external code.
When you talked about how
you swapped your art assets,
and you said, we talked
to people about the art.
Did you the mean play testers,
or did you mean your client,
or did you mean
your team members?
Right?
They're all people,
so which people?
Yeah.
I was assuming play testers
based on the context.
And finally, this has nothing
to do the presentation.
Does the game still
use Fahrenheit?
GUEST SPEAKER: Can
we change that?
PROFESSOR: What
was the question?
GUEST SPEAKER: Fahrenheit?
I don't think we have changed--
PROFESSOR: The game is
still on Fahrenheit.
GUEST SPEAKER: It's
PROFESSOR: OK.
GUEST SPEAKER: We can
change that today.
PROFESSOR: It's a bit risky
to change it at this point.
You might want to list
that on your things
to change in the future
maybe, just add [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's enough.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, that's enough.
I wouldn't touch the code.
PROFESSOR: Don't touch the code.
Please don't touch the code.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Just acknowledge
that, because that
was one of the big
pieces of feedback,
is that only the
US uses Fahrenheit.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR:
PROFESSOR: I'm not following,
so he got [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
PROFESSOR: No.
PROFESSOR: So make
sure it actually plays.
So you're going to demonstrate
it in unity rather than
as a web hosted version?
GUEST SPEAKER: We might
do a [INAUDIBLE] version,
but we haven't had luck yet.
PROFESSOR: OK, cool.
GUEST SPEAKER: We're
meeting after class.
PROFESSOR: Great.
But it looks like whatever
you're going to run it in,
it's going to work
at that resolution.
And is there audio for it?
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
There is.
But it's not playing right now.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Oh, there's some.
GUEST SPEAKER: One of the
things got lost, apparently.
PROFESSOR: So at
least it's not muted.
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm sorry.
PROFESSOR: It looks
like heartburn.
It looks like it
ate something bad.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Thank you so much.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: And thank
you for being first.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I'll
email you the notes.
PROFESSOR: "Hello
Waves," come on down.
GUEST SPEAKER: So it's
a little light on there,
but our game is "Hello Waves."
It's a game about forecast
based financing that we're
developing for the Red Cross.
The idea of forecast
based financing
is using the idea of a forecast
about the future in order
to make decisions that are more
effective than just reacting
to disasters when they happen.
So I'd like to show you a
play through of our game.
It should open up.
Great.
And let me turn on the sound.
[CLASSICAL MUSIC PLAYING]
So this is "Hello Waves."
Here are the instructions.
We would have done a tutorial
if we had enough time,
but this gets the idea across,
and designing a good tutorial
that actually teaches
the player well
is hard to do in a logical flow.
So we have these instructions
that explain how to play,
what the point of the game
is, and a couple of tips
about how the game works.
So if we go into
the play screen,
you see something similar
to what we showed you
a couple weeks ago, where you
have all these different toys
out there, castles.
And as you go through
the days, you'll
see a forecast of
what the water level's
going to be at over time.
And so you can see
that right now.
They're gathering candy.
The water level changed.
This character is underwater,
and so he takes damage.
And so what you
actually want to do
is you want to move
toys out of the water
so that they don't get damaged.
However, they can only move
one castle over at a time.
So because we didn't
think ahead well enough,
we'll see that this
truck will actually
take damage on the next term,
because he's underwater.
Actually, he ended
up not underwater.
We got lucky there.
But theoretically,
he would have.
And so as you go through
it, the end goal of the game
is to build a castle.
And so every toy
when they're home
can either choose
between gathering candy
to feed evacuated toys
or building the castle
to reach your end
goal of the game.
And then the idea
of the forecast
is that you want to use
the forecast in order
to know how much candy
you're going to need over
the next couple of days and
to use it to know when you're
going to need to
evaporate various toys
from their variously
hidden homes.
So back to the presentation.
Full screen.
So we had a couple of challenges
in the design process.
The first and the
major one is really
that we were trying to teach
about forecast based financing,
which was a bit of
an abstract topic.
It's a little different than
just thinking long term,
because you have to use the idea
of there's some information we
know about the
future that we want
to use to make
optimal decisions,
or at least decisions based on
some idea of the risk that's
out there.
But we also wanted
to avoid things
like just pushing
a button to win,
where you have all
the information
you ever need, and
there's just one option
that you know you're
going to pick every time.
And the game has no
thought whatsoever.
And we also needed
to think about how
we were going to communicate
the forecast to the player
so that they could then
use that to make decisions.
One of the problems that we
also ran into related to this
was that we focused a lot on the
idea forecast based financing
as the topic, and then
tried to build a game built
on top of that topic instead
of building a game that
used forecast based financing.
So that held us back
a lot in the beginning
when we were trying
to come up with ideas.
We also had a really difficult
initial target audience
of policymakers-- 50,
60-year-old government
officials, or people at NGOs who
were going to be using forecast
to make decisions of some sort.
And it was supposed
to teach them
about how they can use forecast
to make these decisions,
except this was a really
difficult audience,
because they don't
generally play games.
And they don't
have a lot of time
to learn about
this kind of thing.
And so we couldn't
really expect to get
them to sit down for
a long period of time
and play around with our game.
In order to deal
with these problems,
we came up with a
couple solutions.
The first thing was that we
had no idea what kind of game
would work, or would make
sense, or anything like that.
So what we did is we
just broke our team up
into multiple groups
and came up with a bunch
of different prototypes.
On paper, we had two
different prototypes.
One that focused on
the idea of managing
a city, and its resources,
and its response to disasters,
versus focusing on
individual people,
and how you're going to
move them around to keep
them safe from the disasters.
And then we went
into a whole bunch
of different
digital prototypes--
one that was a text based
game about managing a city.
We had one that looked
like this, where
you had two different
cities, and you
were specifying what
workers were going to do,
or when they would leave the
city in order to stay safe.
And then we would take
the different ideas
that we were learning from
both of these prototypes,
combine them together,
take things out.
And our final prototype actually
uses ideas from all of these.
Another solution that
we got lucky with
is when Pablo came
to play our game,
he told us that we
actually shouldn't
focus on the policymakers,
because he wasn't confident
that he could actually
get them to play the game.
And so we switched our target
to being grade schoolers, which
is why you saw the cutesy art
with the beach and the toys.
This actually made it
a lot easier for us,
because we could target
people who probably
had some experience with
games, or at least wanted
to do something fun, and
would be curious to learn
about our topic.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
for our development
process-- or I can
just speak here, right?
Yeah.
You can speak right from there.
That's fine.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
another big issue,
another set of challenges
that we ran into
was through our
development process.
And so we had initially
issues with communication
and facilitation.
Our team had a wide variety of
experiences and backgrounds.
Some were hardcore gamers,
some mostly mobile gamers.
And so there were initially
a lot of disagreements
on what level of game
we wanted to create,
and what sort of
game, casual versus
hardcore that we
wanted to create.
And so we needed to
overcome challenges
of facilitation and
communication within our team.
Another major challenge
in our development process
that we had to face came
from our design issues,
where for a very
long time, we had
a vague vision of what to do.
We didn't know what kind
of game we wanted to make,
and so we purposely tried
to keep our game ideas vague
as we built prototypes.
But then we ran into issues
where we would have solutions.
But no consensus on
which solution was best,
and where we went for
long periods of time
without having a clear
direction of where
we wanted our final game to be.
So our solutions
for the challenges
proposed by development
were a team structure.
And so we structured
our team loosely
into three subteams-- a
production subteam, which
would take care of production,
like the deliverables,
and making sure that
all the game ideas are
being communicated properly.
A technical team, which
worked primarily with the code
and making sure
the game got done,
and then a user
experience team, which
handled art, UI, and sound.
And so we kept our
responsibilities flexible.
So as team members got
busy over the semester,
or as changing conditions,
lots of different people
contributing,
responsibilities were
able to easily flow between
teams and team members.
And additionally,
another idea we
started with in the
beginning with the idea
of sub-team leaders.
[INAUDIBLE] the two people
marked with the l's.
But that was an idea
we later abandoned
in favor of just having a
more flexible team structure,
or a flat team structure.
Another solution for helping
our development process
was the use of good
code practices.
And I cannot emphasize enough
that this really helped speed
up our development, because we
didn't run into trouble with
code.
It was mostly with design.
So we used Yeoman, which is
a JavaScript module system.
And basically, it allowed
our code to be interoperable.
We can write one module
separately from another module.
So that solved a lot of issues
with dependencies, or people
working in parallel,
because it allowed people
to work in parallel without
overriding each other's code.
We also used good code practice
with state machines and NBC,
which is motor vehicle control.
And so we had a very object
oriented code, very modular.
And when we did need to change
our code, rip it all out
and put it back in, it
actually didn't turn out
to be too painful, because we
just had to switch a couple
objects around.
And then one final solution
that we used for our development
processes were Slack and Scrum.
So Slack is like a
modernized IRC chat room,
and it's very feature rich.
It has a lot of integrations
with GitHub, and Google Drive,
and things like that.
And so that real time
communication actually
made it so that we didn't
really have to meet
outside of class too often.
If someone was working, we
would just email out saying,
I'm on the Slack.
And then people could
meet on the slack.
And it was full featured enough.
We could send attachments
and things like that.
Most of our communication
in person communication
could be done in class.
And in class, we adopted a daily
Scrum format, where we simply
said what we had done
since the previous class
and what our goals
were until next class.
So in the end though, we did
have to cut some features.
These features mainly
were the idea of again,
a tutorial, or multiple levels,
simply because they'd just
be too much content that we
need to play test in order
to make sure that it was
a consistent quality got
our message across,
and also, trying
to add more individuality
to the toys that you saw.
They have different
graphics, but that's as much
as we could do, given
the time constraints.
So kindly just bring it back.
And our three worst
decisions were first,
we did end up
spending a lot of time
on code and assets
that never got used.
We maybe used 10% to
20% of our final work
in our final project.
Actually, maybe that
is a bit overkill.
But maybe 30% of our
final code and assets
in our final project.
This really was due to
this second bad decision,
that we kept the game
and its direction
too vague for too long.
We always were holding
out that oh, maybe we'll
be able to come up with
a better game idea.
Or maybe we'll find
some magic solution
to how we can make forecast
based financing into a game.
And because of
this mindset, we'd
spent probably the first half
of the project just staying
too vague, and that
hurt us in the end,
because we spent so
much time going in all
these different directions.
And really, the decision that
captured those first two though
is the fact that we tried
to make a game on top
of forecast based financing.
So we had forecast
based financing.
And we were like, how can
we scan this as a game?
Whereas once we switched
that mindset and thought,
let's have a game,
and how can we
put forecast based
financing into it?
I think that was the moment that
we then came together as a team
and really started making the
final game that we wanted.
So our best decision.
GUEST SPEAKER: So one
of our best decisions
was that we chose good tools
at the beginning, which
meant that as we went through
all these different prototypes,
we actually didn't have to
completely rewrite our game.
We could pull out the
way that workers worked.
In one game, we could
pull out the view
that we were using
in another game.
And then we could just
combine them together,
and that allowed us to
move quickly whenever we
were changing our prototype.
We also weren't afraid to trust
each other, both, in terms
of what everyone was
working on, but also,
in terms of the decisions
that we were making.
And so when we said that we
had to throw something out,
we all understood that it was
for the good of the project.
And we didn't have
a lot of complaining
or hurt feelings when
something didn't get put in,
or when we decided to throw
out our assets or code.
And when we got
to the end, we had
been through enough
of this vagueness
that we were all
frustrated with it.
And we realized that we had
an idea that we all liked,
and we really got on board
with it and made it happen.
Once we started working
on our final idea,
we saw that it worked.
Basically, every
decision from that point
on was how do we make
this game better?
And we were all on
board with that vision.
Thank you.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
[? PROFESSOR: Anyone in the ?]
audience have [INAUDIBLE] first
before--
AUDIENCE: We can't
see [INAUDIBLE]
across the [? room. ?]
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
We'll have to make all
of our slides darker.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yellow and white.
Like the yellow and white
on your early screen,
I was doing this on [INAUDIBLE].
I realize that's the game,
not the presentation.
But wow.
PROFESSOR: It's also a little
faded in the game itself.
It could be the display
resolution you're using,
so after class, after
we're done with everything,
try different resolutions.
See if it makes a difference.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
That's be great.
PROFESSOR: The music in the
game development was too high.
It was overpowering your voice.
So I think you were
almost hollering just
to be able to be heard.
It doesn't need to be that loud.
So you can just crank
down the volume right down
on the computer or on
the controls over there.
Something that I
had a question for.
You don't have to
answer it today.
But you might want to put
it in your presentation.
How long was the design
of what you eventually
established on the table before
you decided that this was
the thing you were going for?
Because I'm assuming it
was one of your vague--
it came up during
your vague idea phase.
And you're implying that you
were in that mode for too long.
But I don't know how
long it was on the table,
or was it only something
you figured out
at the end of the
vague idea phase?
Because otherwise,
you wouldn't have
been able to switch to
this idea if it was not
on the table in the first place.
And how did you decide this
was it, that the same household
game was going to
be-- I understand--
I think you very clearly
explained the benefits
of deciding this was it.
But how did you come to
the conclusion that it was?
That's stuff I wanted
to hear more about.
But you don't have
to answer it now.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
And just a little
bit of specificity.
You mentioned you spent too
long on that design phase.
I wonder how long that was.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
PROFESSOR: You said Pablo
switched your target audience
for you, telling
us whether that was
because of the game that he saw,
or because of something else.
If you know that information,
throw it in there.
If you don't know that
information, that's fine.
Knowing why you
dropped the team lead--
you mentioned you dropped
it, but you didn't exactly
say why again.
Really quick, we weren't
getting [? blah ?] out of it,
or the flexibility
was more, whatever.
And defining your terms.
You were saying things like
casual versus hardcore.
Give a little bit a definition
of what you mean by that.
It means different
things for everybody.
So what is your use of that?
PROFESSOR: I think
he specifically
said hardcore and mobile.
But there are hardcore
mobile players out there.
PROFESSOR: And casual
can be considered
a version of hardcore,
just in a different way.
So just be a little
more clear, because I
think you were talking
about the target audience,
and the kind of players, and the
kind of games they might play.
So just be a little bit
more focused on what exactly
you mean by that.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
PROFESSOR: That's it for me.
PROFESSOR: So we
can start testing
for observations in
the young man who's
not relaying [INAUDIBLE]
module frame [INAUDIBLE].
It's just a system to
generate the project,
and it posts in the
front [INAUDIBLE].
So again, just show that.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
PROFESSOR: So that's a
terminology issue then.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Clearly,
it worked out
for your team, so we're not
saying, don't mention Yeoman.
It was clearly a good thing.
But just check your
definition of what
it is, because it'll be more
helpful for other people
to understand what it is so
that they can think about
whether the want to
use it in the future.
PROFESSOR: So your demo--
you spent about three minutes
doing it.
We are going to have a
player from [INAUDIBLE] play
your game live, without
getting a lot of help.
You can talk over it.
You can, after a while,
start helping them.
We want to see
them at least just
start playing it on their own.
Decide when you're going
to put that demo in.
You could actually
combine them both together
if you do it at the
beginning or end.
But if you do that, give the
player a little bit of time
before you start talking.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
Sure.
PROFESSOR: That's all I got.
PROFESSOR: Great.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Snap, come on down.
GUEST SPEAKER: Hi everyone.
I'm part of the Snap
team, and this Sabrina,
who will talk about
the front end aspects.
I'll talk about the
back end aspects.
So I think we actually wanted to
start with a demo of the game,
and we'll do a real
demo right now.
So could everybody
go to snapgame.org?
GUEST SPEAKER: You should
turn on your volume, as well.
It'll be interesting
to see [INAUDIBLE].
GUEST SPEAKER: Oh, nice.
My screen's hidden.
And I will also play the game.
Everybody ready
who wants to play?
So the way this game works
is I'll explain it again,
in case anybody hasn't
heard this before.
We're going to give you
a topic, and then you're
going to enter words
related to that topic.
Whenever you enter the same
word that somebody else entered,
you'll get a point,
which we call a snap.
And the topic is algorithms.
And you can cheat by looking
at my screen, but please don't.
I have no idea how I'm doing.
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
What happened?
GUEST SPEAKER: What happened?
Oh.
Oops.
AUDIENCE: We found a UI bug.
GUEST SPEAKER: I think
it's this resolution.
Probably.
I did test this.
I'm sorry.
I never entered this many words.
I can't scroll.
I think we're going
to stop this one.
Wow.
That was impressive.
Justin won, followed
by Rodrigo, and Rachel.
[APPLAUSE]
This is what you guys submitted.
[LAUGHTER]
This is a very MIT heavy.
Domain.
GUEST SPEAKER: Someone
put [? socks. ?]
GUEST SPEAKER: So
that's our game.
So the way we did
this project was we
split up into back end
and front end teams
from the very beginning.
This was a bit of a
challenge for new features,
because initially, we both were
really highly interdependent.
But eventually, it
became really nice,
because it was simpler to manage
a front end and a back end team
individually, and
they generally didn't
need to talk to each other
once the back end was
off the ground.
I think that
structuring our team
with more individual
roles, besides just having
generally back end and front end
people would have been helpful.
UI design was something that
we didn't think about early
on enough, and that's why
the UI is not as polished
as it could have been.
We could have had
somebody just dedicated
to taking information between
the back end and front end,
say, documenting the back
end and making sure everybody
knew how it worked.
We also definitely had
problems with paperwork,
which would have been
nice to have somebody
who was really on top of that.
And then the game design,
as well, was something.
In addition to UI
design, we also
could have had somebody
just looking at the game
and thinking about the core game
concepts, things like scoring
and what we're going
to display to players.
We did a pretty good
job with planning.
We used Asana and Asana
worked really well for us.
It was quite flexible, let
us manage independent task
lists for front
end and back end,
which we think worked well
all the way from the beginning
to the end.
So separating out the task
lists we liked, Asana we liked.
Our project had a
lot of dependencies,
and this was something
that Scrum inherently
had a problem with, and our
tools also had a problem with.
It was hard to
know, for example,
when a task on the front end
and back end were dependent.
There wasn't a good way
to encode that and see
that the back end
needed to get something
done more quickly, because
the front end could use it.
We also had trouble
just creating tasks.
I think that there was a
diffusion of responsibility
as to who would
be creating tasks
and who would be assigning them.
Once the task got assigned,
then it went pretty well.
But we had trouble just getting
all our tasks listed out.
I think the core of
all these problems
was really getting people
invested in the project
and making sure that they
treated it as a priority
and really spent
some effort on it.
Want to talk about this?
GUEST SPEAKER: Sure.
So we also used Slack for
communicating as a team.
And I think it was
really helpful.
I liked the fact that we
could have multiple channels
so that people working
mainly on the front end
didn't have to get all
the communication going on
with the back end.
And then we also had channels
for our Asana and GitHub
so we could see what
was going on with that.
Some problems though where
I feel like people weren't
as active as they
could have been--
I feel like maybe everyone
should have downloaded
the mobile app, or at least
signed up for notifications
so that everyone's
aware constantly
of what was going on.
And if someone mentioned
them in a post.
They were quickly able to
respond and get back to them.
And that's the main thing that
I think we could improve upon
if we use this in the future.
GUEST SPEAKER: So going
a little bit specifically
into the back end, what went
right for us was definitely
our technology.
We used node.js as the
server and socket.io
to do the two way communication
so that you could receive snaps
from other players.
And we deployed on heroku.
All those three things
worked really well.
We had no problems with them.
And the design of the back
end also went pretty well.
It's a pretty simple
server to implement,
and we did a good
job of figuring out
what it needed to support.
We didn't document as
well as we could have,
in terms of what
is the published
API that the front
end should be using.
So in socket.io, you
send all these events,
and the names and the
formats of the events
were not well documented
for a long time.
There wasn't a lot that I would
change on how the back end was
structured and how it went.
But I think maybe we had
too many people working
on it for the small amount
of work that it was,
and it would have helped
if people more people
had worked on the front end.
That's also part of
finalizing and freezing.
If we had just finalized
and frozen the back end,
then we could've stopped
worrying about it
and just moved on.
Networking was
explicitly forbidden
in the rules of the
class, which we did break,
and we intentionally
broke it quite early on.
Networking really didn't
give us very many problems.
We had a couple
heroku issues, where
we had to quickly do a
deploy, or there was a bug,
such as the one you just saw.
But really, heroku went
really well for us,
and you could easily roll back.
And heroku gives you
good documentation
on what code exactly
ran every single time.
We actually have been
deploying to the client.
The client has been using
this for a while now.
These are some of the
tests they've run.
And you can see
that they're quite
different, in terms of
how many teams there were,
how long they went.
I'm not really sure what the
really long games were like.
We still need to talk to Pablo
about his feedback for those.
But indeed, there were
words being submitted
for those entire three hours.
And just to give
you a sense, I'd
actually like to show
one of these word clouds.
So these are much
more serious topics
than algorithms, where
actually, looking at the words
will give you a
sense of what people
are thinking about a
topic that you care about.
So for example,
I think I'll just
include screenshots
of those, because that
doesn't work very well.
So here, the topic
of this conference
is zero poverty, zero
emissions within a generation.
And you can see,
education seems to be
a big theme in this conference.
I can tell that just by looking
at the word clouds, of several
of them, actually.
And a lot of our effort ended up
being focused on the client, as
opposed to the class.
I think that's part of what
made our paperwork fall behind,
is that I've been working a lot
on supporting these runs that
happened in the
past four days, as
opposed to the
deliverables of the class,
because I thought that
this was important.
It's part of why we
have snapgame.org.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Developing the back end,
we were really successful.
But I felt when it
came to the front end,
we struggled a little bit.
I think a main
challenge was the game
is game that was intentionally
made to play person to person,
and have that communication.
And representing that
in a digital game
was a big challenge
that we had to do.
So in our first
design, we decided
we were going to use Phaser, and
it looked something like this.
And obviously, Phaser wasn't
even really being used,
so what was the point?
So we dropped
Phaser, and then we
went to just using Bootstrap.
Here, we're just using
Bootstrap in JavaScript
to handle all the
input from the users.
And then in our final
design with as you saw,
the dots and the drawing, we're
using a JavaScript library
called 2JS.
So what went right was I think
we had really good people
to do UI design.
But we didn't really
begin thinking about that
until later.
And it took us a
really long time
to be able to represent
the game in a really
good way to the user.
There were a lot of challenges
we faced in doing that.
So I will come back to this.
Some of the first
ideas that we had
for how we're going to represent
the information to the player
was by using a word cloud
that we used on the end,
but blurring out the words until
they actually submitted a word.
Then we would display it.
But this is actually
really, really challenging,
and so we didn't want to
spend our time doing something
like that.
Then we considered
having some sort of line
where you're racing
against the other players
to get to the top.
But this isn't
entirely interesting,
so we considered
including both of them.
But then again,
the word cloud, we
ended up deciding that
was too difficult.
So we came up with the
idea of everyone's a dot,
and your score
would be represented
by how big your dot is.
But if you're playing
with 100 people,
this is just unreasonable.
And so then we finally came
up with this last idea,
which is nearly complete,
where the height of your dot
represents where you are in
relation to the max score.
And the lines are
representing snap connections
that are going along
with the other players.
So basically, I think for future
projects for the front end,
we definitely need to
think about design sooner.
This process happened really
slowly and really close
to the end.
We were very focused
on the functionality
of our game and the
mechanics, and not
a lot about the player's
interaction with the game.
It would have been awesome if we
did some prototyping early on,
because we had some other ideas.
And we just never put
them into fruition,
and we never tested them out.
So it would have been
interesting to make
those and see what
users thought of them.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
I think working
with a large group was
definitely difficult.
And splitting it
up was a good idea.
But I think that having more
responsibility and roles
within those people would
have been very helpful.
We also should have thought
about design sooner.
I think also, from Miriam's
presentation, the idea that we
should have thought about
the game and making it
fun was something we
should have focused on,
as opposed to just thinking
about porting a game
that we had seen.
We really should have focused
on what makes this a fun game,
and what could we
do to improve it?
Because the core
game can be done
very quickly, and within
the first couple weeks,
we had the core concept done.
So I think more quickly,
we could have figured out,
what feedback should
we give to players?
How can we make it
more competitive,
which I think it makes it
more interesting as a game,
as opposed to as a
tool to collect data?
That's all we have.
Are there any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Anybody
else from the class?
Any suggestions?
No?
Well, we've got some.
You want to go first?
PROFESSOR: So one
thing that I noticed
was there was a screen where
you had the [INAUDIBLE]
didn't future.
That made no sense to me at all.
I stared at that
slide for a while.
And then I heard what
you were talking about,
and then ah--what worked, what
didn't, what are we going to do
in the future.
I can see how you
might do it, because it
fits with the snap theme of
having just a single word.
But wow, that was
really confusing.
PROFESSOR: Oh, that's
why all [INAUDIBLE]
are in small letters.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
It took me a while to
realize what was going on.
I'm guessing that.
I don't know for sure.
PROFESSOR: Is that what
you were going for?
GUEST SPEAKER: Not really.
It was just for consistency.
PROFESSOR: OK.
PROFESSOR: Slightly more
clarity would be helpful.
You talked about
the task diffusion,
having a hard time
getting tasks assigned.
But when you talked about
dividing your team into groups,
you didn't talk about what
the structure was running
those groups or anything.
You didn't have any of
that was what was going on.
But you might want to be maybe
more explicit about that.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, like
how did somebody take
a task from Asana, by the way.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Was there
a process for that?
Did that actually
happen that way?
Or was it an assignment?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Was there one person
generating tasks?
Or did the groups generate
tasks collectively?
That sort of thing.
I think that's most
of what I have.
PROFESSOR: So first of all,
the demo for the game probably
is what we're going to have
to do on the real day itself,
because it's such
a large scale game.
So it's not going to be like
two people playing the game.
So we can probably run
the demo pretty much
the way that you did.
GUEST SPEAKER:
[INAUDIBLE] that's
what we were [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Is that the way that
they do it when they run it?
GUEST SPEAKER: It depends.
So Pablo has been actually
doing a limited number of words.
And only at the World Bank
are they doing it like the way
we are doing it, where
everybody's submitting.
And that, they haven't done yet.
That's actually this afternoon.
PROFESSOR: You might
want to talk a little bit
about the history of this game.
Everyone in this room right now
has played the original game.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Similar to some of the things.
I have it-- why are all your
subheadings in small letters?
Because it really,
really threw me.
Now, maybe it was
unintended to make it look
like your game [? snap, ?]
but it actually
does make it hard to
read, your slides.
All caps would be even easier
than all small letters.
There's one slide where
you talk about adding roles
for specific game design,
UI, and everything.
But the heading
just says, future.
The big takeaway is
more specific roles.
You'll see it.
So that should be on your slide.
Your slides move
really fast on average.
And some of your slides are
more word-heavy than others.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
PROFESSOR: So for the
ones that are word heavy,
them up a little longer,
or make them less wordy.
One or the other.
Otherwise, I'm trying
to read everything,
and I can't even listen
to what you're saying
before the next slide changes.
When you described
the mobile app,
I'm assuming you meant
an Asana mobile app?
GUEST SPEAKER: The
slack mobile app, yeah.
PROFESSOR: The slack
mobile app, OK.
Just be specific, because
it wasn't entirely clear
what you meant by that.
So yes, put screenshots
into your presentation
instead of switching windows.
That will just
make things easier.
There are maybe
people in the audience
who actually haven't used
Phaser or know what Phaser is.
So when you say, Phaser clearly
isn't doing anything useful,
well, they don't know
what Phaser does.
So just explain.
Phaser's a sprite-based
game engine.
We have no sprites,
something like that.
Two points about
the game itself.
First of all, how do you
tell which dart is yours?
GUEST SPEAKER:
It's the green one.
PROFESSOR: OK.
I think because of
the peripheral vision,
I really did not even notice
there was a green dot.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: So maybe it's
just my eyes or something.
PROFESSOR: I didn't
see it either.
PROFESSOR: OK.
How many people actually
noticed a green dot?
PROFESSOR: [INAUDIBLE]
mine was so small.
AUDIENCE: There was a random
green dot in the screen,
and I couldn't do anything
to it, so I kept [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: There is a
green dot on screen,
and it's really hard
to see a green dot.
There's something
about the way how
the human vision works on that.
GUEST SPEAKER: I think it's
also because there are so
many people.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
GUEST SPEAKER:
We've never tested
with more than five
people, and there
are a lot of dots
on screen when I
don't know how many
people were in that game--
PROFESSOR: I think
it's cool that there
is a dot that is yours, and
that it has a meaning to it.
But just being aware
that that dot even
exists and is
different from the dots
is more challenging than
you might have realized.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: And then finally,
one thing about the networking
thing. it's actually
really, really neat
that [? Heroku ?]
and [INAUDIBLE]
seems to have solved
problems that we
traditionally, in
this class, have just
derailed entire teams.
So it's a possibility that
you just have an awesome team.
GUEST SPEAKER: Yeah.
I think one thing
I forgot to mention
is that we have a
lot of experience
in all of these technologies.
And so that helped.
PROFESSOR: What
happens if somebody
who doesn't know anything about
node.js or hiroku decides,
they're going to make
a networking game?
GUEST SPEAKER: I have no idea.
PROFESSOR: So you might
want to talk about that.
PROFESSOR: Mine, to reiterate--
client support versus class
deliverables was a good point.
Speak more about the client,
and what you did for them,
and what their role
was on the team.
It sounds like they
had a more active role.
And dependencies-- when you talk
about dependencies and scrum,
having difficulty with
that, absolutely true.
What did you do to get past it?
Explain that.
Or if you didn't do anything
to get past it, say that.
But say whatever it is,
rather than-- you do
a lot of [INAUDIBLE] does this.
But you don't go into the how.
So go a little bit into the
how for at least that point.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Would
you need a break?
Or are we good on time?
PROFESSOR: No, let's
just hammer through them.
PROFESSOR: All right.
"Saving Gora Gora?"
PROFESSOR: "Saving Gora
Gora," come on down.
GUEST SPEAKER: So we're the
"Saving Gora Gora" team, us
plus some devs in the audience.
And I'm Liz, and I'll be
starting you guys off.
So quick overview of our game's
goals coming into the project.
We wanted to inform
players about a cholera,
and specifically, the
causes, and the systems,
and the prevention
of the disease.
And our audience, we wanted to
narrow that down really early.
Specifically, we were more
interested in targeting
the younger age
range of 8 to 13.
And we had specific
issues of that, which
we'll talk about later on.
And mainly, we wanted to have
all these education goals
and audience goals; be
a part of a fun game,
basically, like we wanted
our game to be fun,
and not one of those
educational games they play,
and then you fall asleep,
and it's basically a poster.
A quick overview of what the
game ended up looking like.
This is "Saving Gora Gora."
It's a children's
game, and you are
visiting a village of
animals which is falling ill.
And as a player, your
goal is to help figure
out what is causing
the illness and trying
to defend the character
in the game, which
we'll talk about now.
A big part of our
game is narrative,
which is why we're going
to do the demo later,
because we wanted to ease
you into the narrative
without having you
read all the text.
Everyone in Gora Gora is sick.
We have this monster that
is being blamed for it.
He is totally a cool
guy though, and he
wants you to help you
prove his innocence.
You're Kojo.
You're a little
bunny kid, and you
need to work with the
town to prove to the town
that it's not Sal that's
making everybody sick.
It's actually cholera.
Basic gameplay is you're
the main character.
This is Kojo.
And you'll unlock minigames
by exploring the map.
Each minigame will
give you a clue
to prove that Sal is innocent,
and your ultimate goal
is to convince the mayor
that Sal is a cool guy,
and he shouldn't be in that cage
that you see in the background.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
our first minigame
was about water filtration.
And the basis of the minigame
is that friends and neighbors
in the village are bringing
water to Kojo's mom,
because they don't know whether
it's safe to drink or not.
So the goal of the
game is to have
the player decide
whether each water
source is safe to drink from.
And along the
process of developing
that minigame, we had
to actually iterate over
the physical design of
the minigame quite a bit,
because our first idea was
since it's water filtration,
we wanted to make it
perhaps a facility.
But we realized that
wasn't relatable.
It wasn't culturally
relevant to all the kids
who would be playing this
game, so then our final design
ended up being
outside a home, as you
can see in the background.
So a couple other
challenges we had.
First, we had it working
in real time, where
the player had to rush to get
things done in the minigame.
But we thought
that that took away
from the overall purpose
of teaching the kids,
so we made it a
lot more relaxed,
a lot less time constrained,
and allowed player
to play at their own pace.
And lastly, we wanted to make
sure that the game was clear.
The game plan was clear.
But we didn't want to
make it too text heavy.
And we considered
making a tutorial,
but we didn't have enough time
to actually implement that,
so we added some instruction
text boxes on an overlay
to just try to get the
player a brief overview.
And then during
the game, they're
also able to go back
into these instructions
and reread it so it
becomes more clear.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
the next minigame
is a water collection game,
where Kojo, the main player,
needs to help his friend
find a safe water source,
since you have to
go look for water
and figure out where to
drink, or where to get it.
He basically helps
his friend choose
where to get the water from.
So they basically show
you a village map,
and you would choose which
places on the village
map you would want to
get the water from.
In terms of challenges and how
I started developing the game,
we wanted to make sure
it was "fail-safe"
so that even if the player
chose the wrong choice,
then they would get feedback.
They would learn why that
wasn't the right choice,
and then be able to
continue playing the game
until they made
the right choice.
Originally, we did
have an excreter.
You had to find where
you would also excrete.
But we cut that feature
pretty early on,
since we thought it
was less crucial,
and we wanted to focus on water.
And then other challenges
were, as Kevin said,
we had some cultural
issues, in terms of design,
so we revamped our images.
And also, we wanted to provide
more feedback to the player
as they were playing.
So throughout our
development process,
we added things like helper
texts and more explanations
about why you did or
didn't do things correctly.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Our third minigame
is focused around understanding
the symptoms of cholera
and understanding
how important it is
to act early on these symptoms.
So in the game, the doctor
of the village, Dr. Quasi,
is very busy, and he can't
go out into the village
to help patients, because
he has so many patients that
are coming to him already.
So he asks Kojo to go help him
find sick patients to go talk
to his friends and see if they
have any of these symptoms,
tell them to come to the clinic
so that they can get treated.
During the development
of this game,
we initially started
off with the idea
that you'd be helping the
doctor diagnose patients
at the hospital.
But then we realized that this
would quickly turn into a quiz
and wouldn't be as
engaging or as fun.
And it would
essentially be the same
as reading off of a pamphlet.
So we wanted to add
more of a game aspect
to it, so we decided
to make it such
that you are going out
and trying to find people,
and suggesting to them that
they go to the doctor's office.
And then another one
of the cultural things
that we ran into is initially,
you're playing as a kid.
But we initially had
it such that you're
going around and talking
to some of the adults.
And as Pablo pointed
out to us, there's
a much stricter social
hierarchy in Ghana,
and it might seem appropriate
that we are suggesting to kids
that they demand that their
parents go to the doctor's
office, because
that's not something
that would necessarily happen
in the Ghana social structure.
So we decided to change
that around to you're
talking to your friends,
who are the same age as you.
And you're talking
to your friends,
and you're having them go
to the doctor's office.
Some of the challenges
we ran into,
since this is a very
conversation based game,
making sure that the dialogue
UI was understandable,
and that you knew when you
had choices available to you,
to choose, and when
you were talking,
versus the other
person was talking.
This was something that
we had to integrate
over multiple times.
And finally, making sure
that the dialogue was
age appropriate.
Since these kids
don't speak English
as their primary language
and they're children,
we wanted to make sure that
the dialogue was simple enough
for the children to
understand-- but also, still
had the meaning
behind it so that they
realized what actions they were
taking through their dialogue.
And now, we're going to
start our demonstration.
GUEST SPEAKER: So it starts
out with the monster hiding.
And the monster is
hiding from Kojo.
And Kojo's like,
why are you hiding?
And so you see,
people are blaming him
for everyone's sickness.
And so you say you'll help
and you know who to talk to.
But then when you
bring him to the mayor,
he's locked up by the mayor.
And you're trying to convince
the mayor that he's not
the actual monster.
So you can see the beginning
dialogue really sets up
the scene for the story.
And now, as Kojo, I'll
say, I don't know,
but I'll figure it out.
And so now that you're in the
town, you can explore the town.
And you might be able to
talk to some of the people.
And so the people around
town will give you
things that will help you.
So this dog is
giving you matches.
And you might figure
out later, oh.
And now, you see of
matches in your inventory,
and you might be able
to use that later.
So for example,
we can also click
on the different buildings.
And now, we realize that your
friend is missing a bucket.
So you tell them
you'll go look for it.
And we see that oh, the
monkey has a bucket.
So then you can get the
bucket from the monkey.
And then now, you can go back
and tell your friend, oh.
You found the bucket.
And so this brings you
to one of the minigames,
the collection minigame.
And you can see, you
can drag the bowl
to different locations.
And you can also click on the
locations to see what they are.
And you might say, I'm done.
But it looks like this
water spot is rusty.
So that's where the
fail safe part comes in.
And if you eventually drag
it to a good source of water,
it'll say, thanks.
And you've acquired a clue.
So then the next minigame,
as Kevin was talking about,
is you have to purify water.
And so as you see, there's
a lot of help or text
to help you get started.
And you can just drag the water.
It says it's discolored, so I
think we'll have to boil it.
And eventually,
the game, you have
to figure out what to
do with all the water
and collect enough water.
And so I think we'll
just cut that short,
since we're a little
short on time,
and then we'll show
the rest of the game
for the final presentation.
GUEST SPEAKER: So in terms of
like too technical challenges
we ran into first is like
the states and stays there,
obviously, there
are six of these are
and we have to find
a way to work around
keeping a lot of paired
data, in terms of clues
and which games
you had completed,
what dialogues you were on,
which dialogue should show up.
So that was something-- that
was a little bit of a challenge
that we figured out.
And then additionally, balancing
difficulty with accessibility.
So we mitigated that by using
things like helper texts,
and using a hand
cursor when you're
allowed to click on
things-- stuff like that.
GUEST SPEAKER: So
one of the other
biggest problems that
we had, or I would say,
the biggest problem we had
is that our target audience
and [INAUDIBLE] are completely
two separate groups.
We're targetting 8 to
13-year-olds in Ghana.
We're college students
in the United States.
There's this complete
different culture.
And so we had to do
a lot of research
to make sure that our game was
connecting to this audience.
I think we did a good job.
I think we could
do a better job.
We don't know.
We didn't get to play-test
with our target audience.
So unfortunately,
we aren't 100% sure
that this game's going to
connect to these people.
And another challenge is
playing meaningful-- again,
just because [INAUDIBLE].
So things that went wrong.
Our communication
was really good,
but we never talked about
deadlines for things.
We would say, oh,
we will have this
done by the end of the week.
But then somebody would
need [INAUDIBLE] assets,
and it wouldn't be done.
Sorry.
Or we would want to play test
the game at a certain date,
and there wasn't a
running game at the time.
So I think one of the things
that we had a problem with,
just making deadlines, making
sure people were doing things
on a timely manner.
And then we were having
good communication, just not
constant communication.
We were using several
tools, but unfortunately, I
think that's the next slide.
We were using Trello,
meeting weekly.
We did use Slack.
Unfortunately, not
everyone was on Slack.
Not everyone was
using Trello, and not
everyone was able to
go to the meetings,
and so sometimes,
we would communicate
with three fourths of
the team, but there
would be people that were
completely out of the loop.
So things that went right.
We did separate our
team into basically two
different sub-teams.
There were four people
coding, and then me and Liz
were doing the art.
She was doing character art.
I was doing background art
and all of the other assets.
Then we'd have someone
doing the [INAUDIBLE].
And so just by
separating the team,
it made things a little easier.
You didn't have eight people
touching code and breaking
things or five different people
making the art for something
and having completely
different styles.
We had a meeting every
week, pretty much.
Not everyone was
always there, but it
was very useful to
just get up to date
on what everyone was doing.
And then something that
we did early was just
cut a few features.
We cut a fourth mini game that
was picture matchmaking, which
didn't really make sense, so
we just completely cut it.
Just cutting things
like choosing
where to dispose of your waste,
something that we did early
on that helped us.
So then moving forward, things
that we would want to do
is just test the game more.
We would have loved
to find someone
familiar with our
target audience
or to play test with
our target audience
just to make the game better.
Then changing things like
difficulty and making sure
the game is culturally relevant.
I know I would want to play
test more and then change
some of the elements
that I don't
think are too great right now.
And then even going further,
just expanding the game
and making it more interesting,
having more mini games
and having more, an
interesting mystery, rather
than little paragraphs.
That's all.
[APPLAUSE]
RICK EBERHARDT: Thanks.
Any questions?
Comments?
I didn't think so.
OK.
The demo that you
did mid-presentation,
you might want to
rethink how you do that.
Again, you're going
to have somebody
playing the game anyway.
Maybe you could put
some of that description
while they're playing the game.
Maybe you just demonstrate
the map and say,
here's a mini game,
and then you'll
see these mini games in play.
Or if what you're
trying to do is
help us understand
what the games are,
just give us a screenshot.
That's probably enough.
I don't think we
needed it when we
were watching the
presentation to understand
what you were talking about.
I think you did a
pretty good job of that
when you were talking
about individual things.
And then my big question,
what I'd like to know more,
is you mentioned the big
thing as being the research
you did for cultural
appropriateness, what was it?
Tell us what you did
in the presentation.
Maybe even give
it its own slide.
I think it's pretty important.
ANDREW GRANT: The
social hierarchy example
was a very good,
specific example.
We need more of those.
So what changes you actually
had to make once you
realized that was a problem.
You've got it in this umbrella
category of cultural issues,
but the specific
stuff is really cool.
RICK EBERHARDT:
That's it for me.
ANDREW GRANT: Sara?
SARA VERNILLI: No.
I think Rick actually
got most of what I was--
ANDREW GRANT: You might
want to move the Tools
slide before What Went Wrong
because all the way things
worked out, you just
covered that first.
The water filtration
picture, where
you say you can see it
in the background, no.
We can't see it the background.
The background for
that particular slide
was totally invisible
on this projector,
so increase the
contrast on that image
or actually put
it in as an inset.
You two need to warm
up before you present.
Your voices get
louder as you speak,
so practice outside
of something.
Warm it up and
you're more audible.
This is more of a
game design thing.
There is a bucket
right next to the well
while you are trying
to find a bucket,
and every player is going to
say, why isn't that bucket
just good enough?
Stick a hole in the bucket
or something, whatever
is the easiest way to
solve that problem.
That's pretty much all I had.
RICK EBERHARDT: OK.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Last up, Cholera Control.
STUDENT 2: Hi, everybody.
We're Cholera Control.
We're going to make
this really simple.
Our game was about cholera
and it is a strategy game.
You have to sort of
manage many villages
and try to tell them what
they should implement in order
to help prevent cholera
within their village.
And so we're going to
just go through what
went right, what went
wrong, what we learned,
and any future
changes we would make.
So firstly, what went right.
What happened over the
course of the class
is we simplified
the game, and that
was one of the best
decisions we made
that was really hard to do.
Adjusting scope is
really challenging
because there are
a lot of things
you want to have in your
game, you want to happen,
but when you realize
you just can't do it,
it's like a load
off your shoulders
and you can really focus on
the things that are important.
One of the things
we did simplify
is what the player can do.
They have less
actions, and we'll
show that when we
have some screenshots,
but they're more meaningful.
What the player is doing has
a bigger effect on the game,
and so they don't feel like
they're just clicking buttons.
They're actually thinking.
They're strategizing
rather than just,
oh, I need to click
these as fast as I can.
And it's also more
fun for the player.
There's not too many.
There's just enough.
The iteration was really
one of the other things
that went really right.
It was the best
experience in the class
as a whole for changing the game
is when you do that iteration,
it feels really good
when you look back
and you see, wow, look
how far our game has come.
Look at the changes we've made.
And comparing those really helps
you realize the choices we made
are good.
Some of them are bad, but
most of them are good.
And we also had design
meetings that were occasionally
a struggle for everyone to
attend, but when they did,
they were really productive
and really helped the group
know what was going on,
know what had to be done.
And lastly, the
huge design change
we did halfway through
the eight weeks,
this is what it originally
looked like when we
had a full digital prototype.
It was really confusing.
There are four villages.
They had little bars over them.
People didn't know
what that meant.
There's text in the top
corner of the screen
that you can't read
and you couldn't even
read when it was
screen that told
you your money and the
population of each village,
and then those two buttons
that people weren't really sure
were buttons, so that
was really difficult.
This is what it looks like now.
It's much clearer.
There's a nice bar at
the top telling you
your money, how many days,
and a nice little pause menu,
and then there are
only four villages.
They take up the whole screen.
It's very obvious that
you want to click those.
And also, there's a lot
of indicators as to what's
going on in each one.
Before, you had to click
on each village and then
up in the corner,
that text would
change to tell you what's
going on in that village,
and now, you can see it.
It was a quick overview
when you're watching.
And so you have the
population that's sick
and that's not sick, and the
green bar is healthy and red
is infected, and then
an arrow telling you
the direction in which the
infection rate is going,
whether it's going towards
more people getting
healthy or more
people getting sick.
And then you also have
those little circles
beneath each locality.
We call them localities.
It's a better term
than "village."
We wanted it to be very
neutral, and that's
what our clients told
us we should use.
And so below each locality
are those four little bubbles
that show what you've
implemented there,
and they count down.
You might not be able to see it.
It's a little small
on this screen,
but they count down and
become less colored in
or a little bit darker so you
know how much longer it'll
last.
And then for the menu of when
you clicked a village, that's
what it originally looked like.
It was really hard to read.
There were a lot of
choices that you could do.
We had eight, I think, is
there, which at first, we
were like, yeah, this
is a strategy game.
It's going to be really hard.
There's going to be a lot
of choices, a lot of things
you can do, and this ended
up being a very poor choice.
And so this is what it
looks like now, where
it's much clearer, first
of all, how to close it,
how to get back to the main
screen, also what you can do.
When you hover over something,
in the Description box,
its description pops up.
If something's
implemented, which nothing
is in this locality, but if
something was implemented,
that circle would also be
colored in and counting down
to how long until you
can implement it again.
So then what went wrong.
First thing was coding.
Working together is really hard.
We learned this
over the project.
So we thought, OK, we'll
divide everything up.
We'll make it so everyone can
work independently and make
sure there aren't any
real dependencies that
are going to be roadblocks.
But even doing that,
it's still hard
when you have to bring
everything back together
and there were just
inconsistencies.
People had different coding
styles and merging just
took a lot longer than
it should have taken.
Motivation was also
a really big problem.
At the beginning
of this project,
people weren't really passionate
about cholera or making
a game about cholera,
and even as we came up
with designs and interesting
choice and things
we thought would be fun, that
passion just didn't grow.
It was always just
like, I don't want
to do this, which
is really hard.
I don't know how we
could change that.
Also, the topic was
really restrictive.
It's something that
probably that I'm guessing
must happen a lot
in the real world
that sometimes you work on
things that you don't want
to work on, but you have to find
a way to struggle through that.
We also had crunch problems.
Our team was just
a lot of crunches.
There wasn't constant work.
There was a lot of crunches.
And so we had a lot
of crunching right
before a play testing class.
We had a lot of crunching
after Thanksgiving before now,
and the work on the game
was really low priority
because everyone has
other classes that they
need to do things for.
And so it is hard to
tell people, no, you
need to do this
because they're like,
I have a thesis project due.
That's way more important
than a project for this class.
And another thing that
happened over time
is that people weren't adhering
to the communication we
agreed on.
We said, OK, we'll
do emails and we'll
use Gitter, which is sort
of tied in with GitHub,
and then people
weren't on Gitter
or they didn't reply to emails.
And so whenever you
sent out a message,
it was like throwing
it out into the ether
and then hoping
people would respond,
which is really challenging.
Sometimes you forget
to log onto Gitter
or you forget to
look at an email
until later, so it's difficult.
It's something that happens,
but it's a hard
thing to deal with.
So then what we learned.
Within game design,
there's actually a lot
we learned from this project.
The biggest thing is that more
complicated and more choices
does not equal more fun.
It can, and if you're
making a really big strategy
game like Civilization,
I could see
where you'd want to have the
ability to do a lot of things,
but in something
simpler, you don't
need to be able to
do as many things.
But if those things have
meaning, which our choices now
do, it's a lot more fun.
Play testing revealed
that a lot of people
didn't like having
so many choices.
They didn't know what to do.
It was real time,
so people were dying
and they were like, I lost
the game before I even
felt like I started.
Design is very restrictive.
You need to pay
attention not only
to what the client
wants, but also
who you're making this for.
How accessible
does it need to be?
Who's the target audience?
And also, it's really
hard as a designer
to realize you need to put both
the player and the client's
needs before your own.
You as a designer know,
I have this grand vision
of what our game should be,
but then play testers say,
we don't like your vision.
You need to change it.
It needs to do this.
And your clients say, we
don't like your vision either.
It needs to change.
You need to do this.
And so doing that is
very hard as a designer,
but we learned to
do it and the game
was better as a result of it.
Some other things is
none of us knew anything
about cholera when we
started, so we learned a lot
about cholera.
And it's surprising how easy it
is if you just wash your hands.
That's it.
So if you're in Ghana,
just wash your hands, guys.
And probably don't drink
infected water sources,
but the big one is
wash your hands.
And that also applies to
a lot of other things.
Pablo actually asked
us to emphasize
the washing your hands
because Ebola also,
it benefits if people
wash your hands.
It helps you so you don't
catch other diseases.
And then about
coding is tweening
and other animation APIs make
a game look more polished
for little effort, which is
something we didn't really
implement until the end,
and then when we did,
we were like, wow, that
looks a lot better.
And then future changes.
So for just within the
game, things that we never
got to implement but
we really would like to
are subtle effects
that would force people
to change their strategy
because sometimes it
can get really easy, and
so we'd want to make it
so people who quickly
figured out a strategy
and then think,
oh, we can win is
we wanted to make some things
that their strategy doesn't
work anymore.
So we originally we had the
idea of a change in season,
which is something we would like
to do, but time constraints,
or random events where there's
maybe not a change in season,
but there happened to
be really heavy rain
one day so everything flooded,
so now all the water sources
are more infected.
Also, multiple
levels of difficulty.
We did like simplifying
it, but there are still
some things we'd like to
add, at least one more action
and maybe a few more villages.
So that's something
that we would like
to add if we had more time.
And also, more advanced
infection models.
You can talk about the
infection models if you want.
STUDENT 3: I'll chime in there.
It turns out to be
really, really hard
to balance the spread of
infection of a disease.
It's almost impossible to
make the game relatively
simple at the beginning but then
the right level of difficulty
at the end because the
nature of infection
is that it's exponential.
You change a
parameter by nothing
and it just swings
the whole thing over
and makes the game go from very
easy to completely impossible.
So that made it really,
really hard to balance.
If I had more time, if I had a
few more weeks to work on it,
probably the things
I'd want to work on
would be work on
something more advanced,
like some more advanced
mathematical models, as opposed
to just a simple exponential
model that we currently have,
because that could make
game balancing much easier.
I had a really hard time
balancing infection.
STUDENT 2: And
lastly, some things
we'd change for the
class is we wished
that we had something that
enforced the sprint tasklist.
We submitted it every
week but we were never
held to actually doing what
we said we were going to do.
So it felt just like, oh,
it's something we have to do.
We have to say we'll do
things this week in order
to be working on the game.
So we wish there was something
like the instructors asking,
OK, can we see your
completed sprint tasklist?
The restriction to
the Red Cross topics
was a huge constraint
for the creative freedom,
especially for the last project.
So because all of
us didn't really
like the topic to begin with, it
was a really long eight weeks.
So we wish that we
didn't have to do that,
but I understand for this
semester of this class, that
was what happened.
And then another thing
is that we wouldn't
work on an educational
game regarding
an unknown culture
for the final project
because it was just really
hard to understand, OK, what
do people in Ghana find normal?
What would they want in a game?
Do they understand
how this works?
It's something that's
even hard because there
are a lot of
assumptions people who
have played games
make about games
that's really hard to get over.
And so doing that for
the final project that
also has to be an educational
game that also has
to be about cholera,
it's just like there's
a lot of things piling up that
made it really hard to do.
So any questions?
And we'll also show
a demo of the game,
but if you guys want to
ask any questions first.
[APPLAUSE]
Should we do demo first
and then questions?
RICK EBERHARDT: Yeah,
go ahead and demo.
ANDREW GRANT: Both
on this screen
and with some of
the earlier teams,
many of you are running off
Mac and you are using a screen
resolution that's
better for your screen
than for the projector.
So it's actually rescaling it
to fit the projector, which
means actually, every pixel
that you're drawing on screen
is actually too small
for the projector
and things get blurred out.
In the Screen Resolution
Settings in System Preferences,
you can actually select
whether you are scaling it
optimized for either display.
I guess in this case, you are
optimizing it for display.
RICK EBERHARDT: Which
resolution are you using?
ANDREW GRANT: It looks
like you're using 1600.
STUDENT 3: What's the best one?
RICK EBERHARDT: It's on
the board right behind you.
There's a wide screen
and a four three version.
ANDREW GRANT: So check
that because you're
using a lot of
visual detail when
you're scaling it like that.
It makes your games look worse.
That looks way better.
RICK EBERHARDT: And
the color scheme
is going to be better, too.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
Your colors do look
better as a result.
STUDENT 3: Cool.
Awesome.
So we still have a little
bit of things to iron out,
but the idea of the game is
that you manage these villages.
Cholera is spreading
and you have
to use various prevention
measures to stop it
from spreading further.
So when the game starts out,
there's just one village.
People were having
difficulty figuring out
that you could actually click
it, so we made it do like that
so you know you can click it.
So you click it and then
there's various options
that you can use to stop
the spread of cholera.
So it's just the first
village, so I'll just
go with soap, which is
the cheapest option,
and that usually stops.
I'll make it go faster.
The first village is
sort of a tutorial.
Once you've figured out how
everything works and you're
able to stop the infection
there and you cure it,
then a second village pops up.
As the game goes
on, more villages
pop up, up to a total
of four villages.
Basically, at the
beginning, it's quite easy.
You can't really lose
on the first village
unless you sit and stare
at it and do nothing
for three minutes.
But the second village
comes up and now you
have to think about
things, then you
get an idea of how the
game is actually played.
By the time the third
village comes up,
you really need a strategy
or you're going to lose.
And the fourth village, it
just gets really, really hard.
Generally, most people actually
fail in the third village,
don't make it to the fourth one.
I guess if you guys want
to see more game play.
RICK EBERHARDT: Is there sound?
STUDENT 3: So we don't
have sound right now.
We're going to
add that in today.
So the three different
options, basically, soap
is the cheap, all
around option because we
want the takeaway of the
game is soap is overpowering.
These two options
distinguish themselves in
that water containers are
good for stopping an infection
from spreading but they
don't cure anymore,
and electrolytes
don't stop anything
from spreading but
they immediately
cure just a percentage of
the infected population.
What we found is that I thought
electrolytes weren't actually
going to be fun, but
then they are, because
at the end of the game
when the infection is all
over the place and
everyone's dying,
you just keep
spanning electrolytes.
It has a cool down so
you can't keep spanning,
but you span it as much as you
can to desperately stay alive.
I don't know how far
to actually take this.
RICK EBERHARDT:
That's fine for us.
A live player is going
to play it on their own,
so they'll be
figuring stuff out.
Again, give them
a couple minutes,
and then you can start talking
if you'd like to talk over.
For the presentation itself,
when you started out,
we could use a little bit
more context about what
you're talking about.
You kind of just
throw us into what
went right and one of the
things that went right,
so maybe telling us what
you're going to talk about
might be a way to give context
for the full presentation.
STUDENT 2: Would starting with
the game give a better idea?
RICK EBERHARDT:
That would be good,
especially if you're
talking over the game
and talking about
some of the design.
Then we can kind of call back.
SARA VERNILLI: Another
context related issue
is you refer to your client
and you refer to the game
and you refer to making
the game about cholera
but you don't actually
explicitly state
who your client is, what your
game is for, what the goal you
were trying to create your game
for, what specifically it was.
You could gather
it from context,
but it's a nice thing
to have upfront.
ANDREW GRANT: So the early
slides, they're pretty wordy.
Both of you are actually
really good speakers,
so I feel like you can
get a lot of those points
in your actual verbal-- you did,
in fact, get all those points
across in your verbal things.
The slides don't need to also
restate every single thing.
So stick to high level headers,
but the way how you're actually
presenting these points are
coming across very clearly
verbally and the
words are starting
to distract a little bit.
RICK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
Each one of those
could have been
just one slide plus an image.
ANDREW GRANT: That becomes
a backdrop to the things
that you're actually
saying, which are actually
coming across quite clearly
and you don't really need
all of that additional
visual noise,
especially when you
have sub-bullets,
like you have a
heading and then you
have tiny little
sub-bullets underneath.
Those sub-bullets,
just say them.
Don't represent them.
The image of selecting
which updates
you have for each
locality, right now
you have the blank rectangle
with mouseover text in it.
Nothing is lit up.
If you just replace that with
a screenshot of something's lit
up, something's not lit
up with the mouseover
text, that will be way
more informative, that one
slide alone.
When you talk about
balancing the infection rate,
that's a really good
detail case example.
I just want to call that out.
That level of detail
is neat because you're
talking about really
something very specific.
Other things that you
can talk about-- I'm
trying to remember the way how
you had set up a communication
system of using
email and Gitter,
and this is what Gitter is,
but people weren't responding.
That was good.
That was very specific.
That was like, this is
the way how something
specifically broke down.
You can talk about
how things eventually
got resolved would be nice, but
maybe it didn't get resolved,
and you can say that, too.
That level of
specificity was nice.
SARA VERNILLI: One more.
Specifically on the
slides, you talked
about how you did iteration.
You talked about
you made changes
and you stayed
very generic there.
I think some actual
specific examples
we really would like to hear.
What are some things
that you dropped?
What are some things that
you had in the beginning
but you changed a whole lot?
They're in your end game
but we don't recognize it
from the beginning
game because it
got changed [? in right now. ?]
You don't need
a whole lot of examples, just
one specific ones would tie it
back.
ANDREW GRANT: Yeah.
So if, in that particular
section, you just added,
here's a specific
feature that got changed
in this particular way, that's
great because you clearly
have that information.
RICK EBERHARDT: All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you all.
Everyone, sorry we ran a little
bit late, but timing wise,
everything looks
like it went out.
Tech wise, it looks
like we've got
most of our stuff figured out.
A couple points of order.
This did go long.
It's probably going to go about
full two hours on Wednesday.
Do you want to take a
break midway through?
Would you like an
intermission midway through?
I'm seeing some
nods, so we're going
to put an intermission
midway through.
Lastly, based on the number
of speakers that we've got
and the topic matter
that we're talking about,
I think what we're
going to do is start
with Snap because everybody
will have their computers out
from the get go and then
we won't need that again
afterwards.
Just take care of
that right there.
You're going to have people
playing live in the audience.
Then we're going to
go to Hello Wave.
Basically, we're going
to swap Heat Wave
and Snap and Saving Gora Gora
and Cholera, swap those two.
And for that,
because we're going
to have lots of
speakers at the so
that will just make
it so that you're
doing all the moving around.
Cholera Control, you're going
to have two people for that,
so we're going to make sure
we have two microphones
for all of that.
We'll have the intermission
right after Heat Wave.
So that's about an
hour and a half,
and then we'll
have another hour,
and then that's the end
of the class on Wednesday.
ANDREW GRANT: So that's
the order of presentation
right there.
RICK EBERHARDT: Yeah.
One, two, three, four, five.
There we go.
Cool.
I'm trying to think if there's
anything else that I should
get to before we release you.
No.
Student evaluations,
web.mit.edu/studentevaluations.
I'll write up the
real URL right there.
Please do that in class
today if you could.
Thank you so much.
You actually are doing
a really good job.
I really like these
presentations.
I'm really excited
to see what they're
going to be like
on Wednesday, and I
was really happy to see working
games today, so aces on you
for that.